في هذه المأدبة الفخمة للزعيم
الأعلى للذكرى الخامسة والسبعين لتأسيس الجيش الكوري الشمالي
كيم جونغ أون مع زوجته
وفتاة تبلغ من العمر حوالي تسع سنوات، يقول البعض إن الفتاة
يمكن أن تكون هي الفتاة المختارة التي
يتم إعدادها لتكون الزعيم القادم لكوريا الشمالية
من خلال إظهار بعض الجودة
بدا الأمر وكأنه يريد
إظهار عائلته كعائلة جيدة ومستقرة، كما
يقول، وإظهار نفسه
كقائد للأشخاص العاديين،
فحياتها ليست عادية على الإطلاق،
اسمها كيم جو في سن المدرسة الابتدائية، وقد
تفوقت بالفعل على  غرفة مليئة بكبار
الضباط العسكريين
تصفها وسائل الإعلام الحكومية في كوريا الشمالية
بأنها ابنة كيم المحترمة وتحظى
بحفاوة بالغة وهي تنادي صديقي، إنه صديقي،
عرفنا اسمها لأول
مرة من دينيس رودمان، الصديق السابق للاعب
كرة السلة المحب كيم، الذي ادعى أنه
تمكن من التمسك به  الأميرة ذات الحجم الصغير في
عام 2013 عندما كانت طفلة قبل بضعة أشهر،
كشفت ابنة كيم
لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية الكبرى عن اختبار صاروخ باليستي عابر للقارات في
مطار بيونغ يانغ وتفقد
أرسنال والدها الثمين في أرسنال،
يمكنها في يوم من الأيام أن تأمر
مصدرًا يتمتع بمعرفة عميقة
بالشمال  القيادة الكورية تعارض
فكرة أن هذا كان خليفة، حيث
كشفت لشبكة CNN أنه من السابق لأوانه
وضع أي افتراضات أو التحدث عن أي
خليفة محتمل بالتأكيد، إنها
إشارة واضحة إلى أن الرئيس كيم يرسل
للعالم التزامًا ثابتًا بحماية
عائلته ومستقبله.
إذا تم اختيارها لأجيال مع البرنامج النووي، فستكون
أول أنثى والجيل الرابع
من قيادة عائلة كيم مثل جدها
وجدها الأكبر، صيغة
الأسرة تخشى السيطرة وحملة
علاقات عامة دعائية مصممة بعناية
تشيد بقوة قادة المستقبل
وبراعتهم  يمكن أن يكون فتى أو
فتاة أصغر أو أكبر لا يهم
المهمة الوحيدة هي الحفاظ على
ثروة عائلة كيم وقوتها
لفترة من الوقت، كان يُنظر إلى شقيقة كيم الصغرى كيم يو
جونغ على أنها خليفة كيم المحتمل في نهاية المطاف، وقد
اشتهرت
بخطاباتها النارية التي اشتهرت بتوجيهها ذات يوم.  قررت
القوات المسلحة للبلاد
تفجير مكتب اتصال مشترك بالقرب من الحدود،
والآن عيون العالم تتجه نحو
الخبراء الذين يقومون بتحليل كل صورة
وكل مقال بحثًا عن أدلة حول
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي القادم المحتمل، وكل
ذلك على الأرجح قبل عيد ميلادها العاشر